there's fine tension my intention to run
again and we have time to make that
decision Joe Biden intends has said he
intends to run for re-election as
president and I intend to run with him
as Vice President of the United States
the president has been very clear about
this he intends to run in 2024.
not so fast somebody may be getting cold
feet it turns out President Biden is no
longer certain about a second term he
was supposed to launch his 2024 campaign
in February but now the timetable keeps
getting pushed back Democrats are
wetting their pants as Joe drags his
feet his delay is causing nervous
chatter in the party top aides and
potential candidates are developing a
plan B and keeping their options open
and if Joe makes another go at it get
ready for basement Biden to return while
no Campaign Headquarters have been
picked the president reportedly wanted
to be his Wilmington house that's
Hunter's former party pad and where they
kept classified documents next to that
Corvette in the garage so Democrats may
be panicked but Bernie in the far left
had given Biden their blessing
I think he is a much more Progressive
president than he was a United States
Senator and I think as a result of the
campaign and the task forces we did
together you recall we had task forces
during his campaign and my campaign I
think we came up with an agenda that was
Progressive
and as a 2024 chatter picks up the
liberal media is taking Jabs at
potential Rivals from both sides of the
political aisle in my view there are
three states yet you can't really run
from if you're trying to win Across
America you run from New York you're too
crazy you're liberal you run from
California you're too crazy you're
liberal you're trying to make sure I
can't get plastic straws you run from
Florida it's all crystal meth and
alligators right like I mean that's
that's what people think and I'm not
saying that that's the case I'm saying
those are sort of the national
reputations of those States
yeah crystal meth and alligators all
right Jesse welcome back thank you all
right I'll go right to you is his delay
creating a sense of doubt and what is
the impact for the party and for him
well it is creating doubt and that's why
Politico came out with this and you have
Newsom now who's waiting and a lot of
the donors are kind of nervous but I
know somebody that had breakfast with
Joe Biden one time and it was at a diner
and you know those Diner menus that are
like five pages yeah he sat there for 20
minutes everybody else had already put
their order in he could not decide what
to order he ended up going with waffles
but that's how indecisive this guy is
yeah A lot's changed though recently
you've had the FBI raid three of his
properties and the University of
Delaware he just took out a quarter
million dollar line of credit against
his house to pay lawyers he doesn't
really know what's going on with the
hunter situation but that could go
anywhere the House Republicans have just
really begun the investigation and we
already know treasury's hiding 150
suspicious wire transfers right so he's
kind of watching he's watching Trump
he's watching the indictments he's maybe
waiting to see if DeSantis ever gets in
but I remember reading this book about
LBJ it wasn't LBJ was like I'm too old I
don't want to run again Bobby Kennedy
said you're not running and there was
also a sex scandal that was bubbling up
from one of his cohorts in the Senate
that was going to crush him before JFK
got assassinated and all the good old
boys wanted to put Nixon in there so he
didn't really decide himself it was
decided for him he also just took the
physical now I don't know what happened
with the physical they say he's fit and
ready to rock but the man just fell
again on the steps of air first one
that's true four times he's fallen with
his dog twice on Air Force One and off
the bike so there could be some things
we don't know about and I'm sure he
doesn't want to leave things in the
hands of Kamala Harris
well you never know I mean she sounded
good in the last interview but let me
ask you this if if he decides not to run
Dana who does that benefit
well I if I was a betting person I would
bet that he's running because he this
morning NPR had their poll that just
came out he was at 50 approval that's
the highest he's been and they they
truly feel that they have to win at
their back think about after the State
of the Union they're like look at us we
are just running Victory laps around the
Republicans so I think that he's running
I I think it's very strange to say that
you want your Campaign Headquarters to
be at Wilmington I mean a campaign is a
serious operation you have to have a lot
of people this is not 2020 when you're
going to run from the basement that is
not going to be an option this time I
think if the White House had a magic
lamp and they rubbed it and the genie
came out and said I'll Grant you one
wish it would be please could we switch
out Kamala Harris without a lot of
political Fallout because of all for all
the reasons I think that he's going to
run that is an issue that I think
they're really thinking about which is
they'd probably think that he is the
best person to take on a republican but
they know that one issue will be his age
and what happens to him if what happens
to us to the country and to him if he
doesn't make it through a second term
Kamala Harris would be your president
and I think that Republicans would be
able to exploit that very well now one
thing he could do though if you're
thinking that he's not going to run is
like well if he leaves now he can say he
himself said I'm a transitional figure
I'm just going to be the transitional
president so transition to what
presumably that means a younger
generation but if that's actually going
to happen then somebody needs to like
get moving right away
okay peers from your perspective across
the pond what do people in the UK think
of him
I think that most Brits would probably
say by the way we're in no position to
lecture about political leadership we've
had three prime ministers well we've had
three prime ministers in the last eight
months one of whom lasted for less time
than the lifespan of the lettuce so I'm
not going to start lecturing America
about your political life what I would
say is that you have 320 million people
in this great country you are the great
superpower of the world and at the
moment you are heading to a situation
where the next election will be fought
by a man who will be 86 if he were to
win and serve that term or a man he'll
be 82 if it's Donald Trump and I think
most people outside of America think
really that's the choice that's the best
you can come up with in America the
United States brimming with talent and
youth and vibrancy so I think that's the
general perspective of it I mean as in
relation to Biden I think the biggest
problem is only 37 percent of democrat I
think you should run again this is his
own party right so the majority of his
own party do not think he's right but
there are two questions aren't there one
is should he run and one is will he run
I think the answer to the first is no I
don't think you should but the last of
the second is wild horses will not stop
Joe Biden from running again I can
guarantee every tiny particle and you
look at him look at his body language
since the midterms in particular he
thought he's going to get flatlined he
didn't now he's got his Gander up he's
out there he's shouting a lot on the
stump I think is guaranteed he's going
to run got his Gander up yes are you
familiar with that phrase that's right
I'm not and you know Brian he will be
the oldest and one of the lowest rated
uh presidents to run for his second term
uh how do you think it plays out uh just
on that same poll I I the NPR says 50 of
Democrats and Democrats leaning
Independents think they have the best
chance to win with Joe Biden regardless
of the opponent which is sad for the
political process I think when you look
at people that could run yeah you know
there is no Bobby Kennedy in the wings
nobody close I mean if people judge if
he produced like governor is produced in
his position like a cabinet secretary
did like Mike Pompeo did in two
positions they'd be saying wow this guy
could probably do it but he's been
terrible he's been lazy the vice
president's been awful and she's been
lazy she's been given jobs and just
ignored it so they just say look out
Gavin Newsom he's got his ducks in a row
he's got this huge online uh presence of
Phil Murphy of New Jersey says he's
definitely be thinking about taking the
next step also wrote Kahana who worked
for uh Bernie Sanders said okay uh if
Bernie's if Joe doesn't run Bernie's
gonna run which means he's got no chance
and rokahana hasn't ruled out him
running let alone for the Senate these
aren't Stars I think Democrats would
actually agree with me there's nobody
here as a star the problem with Gavin
Newsom is he's terrible a terrible mayor
who destroyed a city and a terrible
governor who destroyed a state and now
it's in in in the red he thinks it's
great that he beat a recall the fact
that he had a recall is an embarrassment
so this is a bad time to go last you
guys all made brilliant points but just
in terms of who's next I don't know well
the good thing about Newsome he's got
great hair and he'll play that right
something I should have said that I
should have led with him
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now